okay so let's now dig in in more detail
to the security clearance fiasco I
referenced it before the interview with
Alexander now to pause now let's dig
into it in more detail
I've already reminded you that Jared
Kushner security clearance is very very
suspicious he lied on his initial
security clearance application forms the
decision was made that he shouldn't have
a security clearance reportedly Donald
Trump got involved unclear who said what
and to whom concerns about Jared Kushner
being in the pocket of Qatar and Saudi
Arabia but ultimately Jared Kushner ends
up with a security clearance let's now
focus in on Ivanka Trump the questions
about Ivanka Trump include is she going
to be pulled into any of the probes that
are now going on has she been involved
either directly or indirectly implicitly
or explicitly in the criminality of the
Trump family we don't know but three
sources familiar with the matter are now
telling CNN that Donald Trump
specifically pressured his then chief of
staff John Kelly as well as White House
attorney Don McGann to give Ivanka Trump
a security clearance after the
recommendation was made that she not get
one let me remind you just last week
Ivanka Trump claimed that Donald Trump
had no role in her getting a clearance
now before I show you the clip if you
believed her last week I have a bridge
to sell you
it wasn't believable when she said it
but she did say it here's a reminder
there are a lot of investigations going
on as you know Democrats launching new
ones this week one of them into the
clearance process some of that you and
your husband now have security
clearances but there were some issues
early on and there are a lot of people
that question whether you were given
special treatment by the President
overriding other absolutely officials
can you speak to that there were
anonymous leaks about there being issues
but the President had no involvement
pertaining to my clearance or my
husband's clearance what were the
problems early on there weren't any
other than a backlog that exists of
close to a million clearances
government this isn't new very clearly
says Donald Trump had no involvement
directly contradicted now like half of
what these people say by three sources
familiar with the matter so let's list
the concerns first of all the White
House is lying they are all lying all
the time they can't be believed polls
confirm this more Americans believe
convicted felon Michael Cohen over
Donald Trump by a 50 to 35 margin
according to the new Quinnipiac poll
that we talked about earlier today this
is just part of the constant lying that
the Trump administration and his family
is engaged in number two these are not
political games okay these are unelected
individuals like Ivanka Trump and Jared
Kushner they are not subject to Senate
confirmation because they are just
advising and working for their father in
a role that has skirted anti-nepotism
laws and Senate confirmation they were
determined not to qualify for security
clearances and they got those security
clearances anyway this is a national
security risk period there's not any
other way that you can couch this if you
are for national security being a
priority if you're for law and order if
you're for keeping the country safe
which Republicans claim to be you have
to be against this there's no other way
to explain it but it's actually even
worse than that because as House
Democrats have been learning about the
sketchiness around Ivanka and Jared
Kushner security clearances they've
started to requisition documents they've
requested documents from the White House
actually more than once at this point
and the White House is straight up
refusing to provide them so John Kelly
needs to be called before Congress to
testify
Don McGann needs to be called before
Congress to testify but if banca and
Jared also need to because the
criminality must be stopped the lying
must be stopped
unfortunately that doesn't mean that it
will but these are not political games
right this is not oh how much do we want
to keep talking about the crowd size at
Donald Trump's inauguration this is a
very very different thing secure
clearances are serious business there is
a process in place to determine who
shouldn't shouldn't have them and the
idea that unelected individuals who were
never subject to Senate confirmation
shouldn't have security clearances in do
should make anybody who's concerned
about national security absolutely and
totally horrified and unfortunately the
easiest path towards getting all of
these people out of positions of power
is not going to come at the result of an
investigation it's not going to come as
a result of impeachment
we're only 20 months from the election
they can all be voted out in 20 months
and at this point that is the quickest
and most direct path to making that a
reality and I'm going to keep mentioning
that as we get one day at a time closer
to the 2020 election